[The film was] really really inspiring to watch - one of
the main themes was obviously Meg overcoming
her insecurities, mm-hmm, what was the
biggest insecurity each of you had at
that age and how did you overcome it? I
did not like the way that I looked, I
think, that was a big issue I had I grew
up in an area where the
sort of ideal of beauty was very
different than what I looked like and
that was something that started at a
young age and then carried on and I
think later in my 20s as I got sort of
more professional success and was
surrounded by people who didn't have
this, and moved away from the place I
grew up, I think I that I and definitely
my 30s I gained more confidence but I
still struggle with it but I that was my
big fear back then. Mine too - I wore
coke-bottle cat eye glasses, I
hated them so much I went to my mother
saying, "gee could I please get a pair of
octagon glasses?"
She said we couldn't afford it so I
accidentally staged a robbery... *Laughter* And broke them...I had myself put in the hospital...
I thought was the reason why I was not
being accepted and ended up having to
get some new glasses so yeah. Well your glasses look amazing today! Thank you, and now I
wear them all the time but yeah I hated
glasses. I had glasses too, I hated my glasses I was so
embarrassed. I was embarrassed of my glasses.
I was a late developer so when I was
14 all the other girls had boobs and
stuff and I was so embarrassed that I
didn't. I would hide in the locker room
and change my clothes in a way that no
one would ever see my body. Wow. I had a similar thing with the glasses.
Really? Yeah...What's one quote that you
live by,  each of you?
Erm, my mother said uh "you cannot say I
love you before you can say I" which I
think is, very useful. My mother used to always say "if you
want something done do it yourself". True. Uh, the
woman who was like a mother to me Maya
Angelou has a wonderful poem called "To
Our Grandmothers' and in the poem she
says "When you learn,
teach, when you get, give." That's beautiful.
I'm getting emotional! When you learn, teach, I love that. When you learn, teach, when you get, give.
Obviously I can imagine you
guys had lots of fun on set together...
What's your favourite memory from working
together on this, would you say? The first
thing that came to mind was Mindy falling... *Laughter*
That's so mean! This is this is just a funny memory I
don't know if it's anybody's favourite memory
but I'll say it was my favourite too. We
were in, we've been to so many amazing
places in this movie, I mean Ava really gave us the gift of seeing the
world and for me seeing the different
worlds of green screen and being in
a fantasy movie for the first time,
but there was a scene we were just doing a
very ordinary shot in the backyard of a
house and we're sitting and the three of
us were saying goodbye to Meg and we shot
this after we had shot all of our stuff
in the States and we're standing there
and Oprah's telling her, giving her
advice about you know we're saying
goodbye and we're parting words and my
costume, it was one of my bigger costumes
and for some reason it just I think I
lost my footing because we wore these
really high stiletto shoes and I slowly
fell, out of frame behind them as Oprah
is talking and Oprah can kind of see me but doesn't, you just didn't want to...
It's just her and this
great big quilted skirt, just falling...Like a wedding cake. And Mindy kept going, "I'm falling, I'm falling..."
One of my favourite memories is being in the
trailer one morning and I brought all of
these English muffins that I wanted everybody to sample. And we're just toasting so many
muffins that the fire alarm goes off and
everybody comes running to the
trailers because we're gonna set the
trailer on fire... Toasting muffins. But these
muffins, oh my Gosh. I could have one right now. She had this jelly... Oh the jelly! We ate a lot. We enjoyed ourselves.
Oh my God, I wish I was there with you guys.